almost all American journalism is
controlled by a few massive corporations
news voice is a one-of-a-kind mobile app
that tracks the bias and corporate
interests that infuse the news stories
we consume every day and it's completely
free to use go to news voice dot-com
slash Pakman to download it so as I said
I have so much to catch you up on from
this weekend I took two days off from
all of this from time to time this is
really important to do so when we were
done on Friday early with the show all
the way through Sunday evening I was
basically trying to pay as little
attention as possible to what was going
on now it's difficult because every time
I do a zoom chat with my friends this is
at what they want to talk about the
virus and I understand that but when I
reconnected with the news on Sunday
evening started to prepare today's show
an unconscionable amount of things had
happened over the weekend every day is
like a week in the old news era by which
I mean like three months ago before the
virus and at that point every week was
already like a month under Donald Trump
so these are strange times and as I told
you earlier Trump has been ranting about
the so-called ratings of his coronavirus
press briefings despite the fact that
bodies are literally stacking up and
being forklifted into the backs of
trucks one of the most tragic tragic
things we've seen in the United States
for a long time and this is another one
of those horrible examples that shows
Donald Trump's utter lack of concern for
the human toll it's really the absolute
worst of Trump that we've seen well Fox
News seem to realize that yesterday
during the press briefing yesterday when
Donald Trump started ranting about his
ratings Fox News immediately realized
we've got to run interference here they
panicked they jumped in cut the audio
from Trump's briefing and reinterpreted
what it was that we were hearing only
coming back when Donald Trump was done
with that rant perfectly timed to run
interference for Donald Trump take a
look at this clip we shouldn't have
bigger ratings in The Bachelor or as the
New York Times said we have Monday Night
Football the president talking about
battling the coronavirus in a rose
garden ceremony for Americans who have
wondered how long life will go on the
way
we've come to know at the last couple of
weeks the answer at least another month
April thirtieth now the target date for
the social distancing guidelines this as
America takes the lead in the number of
coronavirus deaths worldwide please stay
tuned to this Fox station and Fox News
Channel for continuing coverage I'm John
Scott in New York we will continue now
on Fox News Channel our coverage of the
president's rose garden ceremony news
conference I should say talking about
the White House response to the corona
virus let's continue to listen thank you
very much
hilariously the interruption is an
anchor saying Trump is talking about
battling the virus no he's not he's
talking about ratings he's attacking the
New York Times he's saying that he's
getting the ratings of the bachelor and
Monday Night Football for these
completely unhinged gongshow press
briefings about the virus but you've got
to hand it to Fox it's sort of
beautifully done they didn't just cut
away they actually had an anchor
reinvent and reinterpret what Donald
Trump was saying Trump was ranting and
raving against the New York Times and
bragging about ratings and the
voice-over says we're watching Donald
Trump talk about fighting the
coronavirus which is not really what it
was that we were watching at the time
this is why Fox News viewers have no
idea what's going on and by the way I
might get to this more tomorrow Gabriel
Sherman is reporting that Fox News
executives are actually concerned about
legal liability they're worried they
might start getting hit with lawsuits
for downplaying the virus and spreading
propaganda for so long they ultimately
booted that lunatic Tricia Regan who
went on that coronavirus hoax rant that
it you know it's not criminal but it
feels as though it should be and I'm not
literally saying that but it feels as
though which that rant that she went on
a couple weeks ago should have been
criminal in some way Fox News is
concerned about the fact that they've
been downplaying this one of the
earliest purveyors of disinformation
spreading false and misleading claims
and they're now worried they could be
facing legal liability as a result of
their Corona
virus coverage so there it is the full
circle people are dying
so people become anxious mental health
issues are skyrocketing healthcare
workers don't have the equipment they
need we don't have masks and Trump is
bragging about his ratings which are
just scared people looking for some hope
some comfort and Fox News runs
interference cutting away when Donald
Trump starts doing these absolutely
immoral sociopathic rants we are
effectively in a reality show and in
that sense Trump talking about the
bachelor makes sense but people aren't
watching his press briefings like they
watch The Bachelor they're watching
because they're scared and unfortunately
seeing the incompetence of Trump every
day is only making people more scared
the latest approval ratings reflect that
and I hope to get to those tomorrow